Transcription: Cecilia Sarlangue
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Animatrice : Bonsoir à tous.
Bonsoir Roberto, je suis très,
très heureuse et honorée
de t’accueillir au TEDx Alsace cette année
et de t’interviewer aujourd’hui.
Tu es un artiste assez connu
puisque tu es de Mulhouse, n’est-ce pas ?
Roberto MONTANARO : c’est ça
A : Peut-être que certains d’entre vous
dans le public le connaît déjà.
Ou du moins de nom, Montanaro.
Tu es sculpteur plasticien.
C’est bien ça ?
RM : C’est exactement ça.
A : Et tu es parti… tu as réalisé un CAP,
il me semble, de modeleur-sculpteur.
RM : Sur bois.
A : Voilà, tout à fait.
A : Ici, en Alsace, à l’âge de 18 ans.
RM : c’est ça.
A : Et tu as décidé ensuite de faire
un voyage autour du monde.
Tu es parti dans différents pays,
on peut en citer quelques-uns ?
RM : Exactement,
j’ai commencé par l’Amérique,
puis je suis allé en Afrique
et après en Asie du Sud-est.
A : alors on va te découvrir ici,
une photo,
celle-ci
au Soudan à l’âge de 20 ans.
RM : Exactement.
A : Qu’est-ce que les voyages
t’ont inspiré ?
RM : Les voyages m’ont inspiré d’écrire.
J’ai eu envie d’écrire un bout de ma vie
donc je pense que le voyage
permet des expériences
et pour s’en souvenir,
les écrire, c’est intéressant.
A : D’accord. Il me semble que tu as aussi
l’âme d’un écrivain.
RM : Entre autres.
A : Et donc durant ce voyage,
tu as eu des inspirations
au travers de l’écriture ?
RM : Tout à fait et
puisque je suis également sculpteur
et que j’ai beaucoup voyagé
pour sculpter avec les autochtones
dans différents pays,
donc j’y ai écrit bien sûr
et j’ai été inspiré pour réaliser
une de mes dernières œuvres,
qui est la Pointe de Plumes,
qui est d’ailleurs exposée
devant la coupole.
A : On va la découvrir ici
en images et en vidéo.
RM : Oui puisque c’est un mapping.
Donc là, la pointe de la plume,
qui est pour moi et selon moi
le symbole de notre civilisation
puisqu’elle est notre culture,
notre histoire, intellectuelle,
littéraire et artistique.
Et il m’a il m’a semblé bon
de projeter des lettres qui tournent,
des phrases qui tournent en boucle dessus
pour faire de cet outil
le support de l’écriture actuelle.
Voilà, c’est-à-dire l’écriture numérique.
A : Donc vous pouvez retrouver
cette œuvre qui a été installée
sur le parvis devant la Coupole.
Quand vous sortirez tout à l’heure,
vous pourrez prendre une petite
dose d’art et d’enchantement.
Il me semble que tu as aussi créé
une dernière œuvre récemment
qui est très symbolique pour toi
qui est mulhousien,
qui est le symbole de la route Mulhouse,
qu’on connaît aujourd’hui toujours en 2D
mais que tu as réalisé
aujourd’hui en 3D.
Tu peux nous en dire un peu plus ?
RM : En fait, Mulhouse et ma ville natale.
Donc j’avais envie de véhiculer
une belle image de ma ville,
en tant qu’artiste,
et donc j’ai sorti de la 2D
ce symbole qui est
le symbole universel du progrès
pour le réaliser en 3D
et de le faire évoluer, donc j’ai fait
progresser le symbole du progrès universel
et j’y ai mis en ornement
à cette sculpture,
donc là on la voit en bois et en bronze
de différentes dimensions,
j’y ai intégré l’histoire industrielle,
textile et mécanique.
On peut voir les indiennes et les rouages
de la mécanique en ornement.
A : Donc finalement, pour résumer,
je dirais que tu donnes beaucoup de sens
à tes créations.
RM : Tout à fait, je donne
du sens à mon travail,
je donne du sens à mes actions
et j’essaye de donner
du sens à mon histoire
et j’essaie d’enchanter ma vie.
A : Très bien, c’est magnifique !
Merci Roberto pour cette petite aparté !
RM : Merci
[Applaudissements]